this should be a weapon in The Hunger
Games arena I like that it is an
eggplant emoji on the front or maybe I
down it looks almost the same color as
my nail hey fry oh I think you just gave
me pants I don't think this is real
toothpaste all right I'm done hey who's
that Taylor would you please smell my
breath
sure it seriously smells like nothing
I'm actually getting like minty smell
how I am terrified I'm not like as much
of an enthusiast as most of the people
on the internet but I like baking dougie
Ron I like bacon it is a breakfast food
though so I guess it works in the
morning it does smell a lot like bacon
it smells like a dog who just ate beggin
strips and puked it up all over the
floor so I'm pretty excited to put it in
my mouth right now nope this is not
messing around it actually tastes like
bacon there aren't really words to
describe this I've already brushed twice
I want to keep brushing more because
it's enjoyable give it to me let's go
okay Oh Christmas sausage it's bacon uh
that's gross oh my god jasmine mint that
sounds like a toothpaste flavor unlike
eggplant or bacon can we just take a
moment to appreciate this packaging it
makes me feel like this is what they
used in the olden days I don't think
that's accurate but you know looks like
there's a flower on my toothbrush hmm
this is a toothpaste you could take home
to mom this is the only one that rivals
normal toothpaste and the
tastes when you're done with this can I
have this because this is really great
oh well first of all your breath is bad
it's actually like enjoyable it totally
smells like jasmine tea I'd make out
with somebody who used this I'm kind of
nervous about this
it smells like curry I don't know why
you would ever want to brush your teeth
to smell like curry oh they're really
bad there's a like a refreshingness
that's surprising to the curry just the
way he's smacking his lips is scaring
the heck out of me that does not smell
like curry that's gnarly that was a
really strange experiment that I just
participated in the best part about this
week was that I got to brush my teeth
after lunch I get you Brazilian it's
hard to pick which one is the absolute
worst cuz they're all bad I don't care
if target has a deal on any of these I'm
never buying them I'm not buying
two-for-one or ten for seven no yeah
I'll stick to the regular toothpaste I
like feeling so fresh and so clean sure
why not I need to keep asking us better
we'd make out together just once mate